my fear is that uh the over
an over coddled parent uh combined with
excessive amounts of social media
combined with the addictive qualities
of a phone that there's a generation
where too many people in that generation
are not learning the skills
to deal with stress right and we see
this with increasing rates of uh
depression and anxiety in its worst case
uh suicide right yeah absolutely
is there a balance that you see in which
humans that technology can work together
where it's sustainable and there's
longevity to that
and creates resilience of course yeah of
course
i mean that's like saying you know is
there balance between alcohol and human
beings
of course of course you know excessive
drinking yeah
not good not good for any of your
relationships or your own health well
excessive technology
not good for any of your relationships
or your health of course there's balance
yeah
um and it's about being responsible you
know we we
know that other dopamine releasing
things like gambling or smoking
or alcohol right that we have laws to
help us but we also know that there's a
responsibility that comes with those
things
um but we don't really talk about the
responsibility that comes with
technology
um we've all felt it you know you you're
out with a friend and they're on their
phone the whole time
uh it doesn't feel good right um you
wake up in the morning and the person
uh you live with you know checks their
phone before they
say good morning to you it doesn't feel
good you're out with a friend they pull
out
their phone you feel stupid cause you
pull out your phone it doesn't feel good
right um and so it's you know i think we
have to learn
the skill to balance these things
because it's a gift to our friends it's
a gift to the people we love
it's not even a selfish thing it's a
service right so we start to see
learning to find balance of technology
in our lives as a service to the people
so they feel loved that they feel that
we're present with them
i think it's a better way of treating it
as opposed to i have to get a handle on
this
but rather i'm going to do it for you